what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading onto my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
so as you guys know when it comes to our
discussion on comic books I like to go
out between the pages so to speak you
know beyond the veil when it comes to to
come about concepts and topics and so on
and so forth because for a lot of people
comic books are very personal in the
sense that you know they might represent
different aspects of their life or they
might help them get away from an
otherwise unbearable situation
regardless of what that might be but
where a lot of people comics serve a
very deep purpose not only that for a
lot of people comic books are really
like a reflection of a time in which
they atomic they long for um I guess
support is simply when it comes to the
world of comics nostalgia is everything
people long for a return to a specific
aspect of their life where a specific
aspect of comics I for example love
1990s x-men I loved the you know Gimli
Chris Claremont era of x-men Scotland L
wasn't bad he gave us onslaught saga you
know I like that era of comic books and
I would give almost anything to go back
to that era of comic books of course we
can't and so we just kinda have to work
with what we have right now which
doesn't mean things are bad in fact some
kind of the characters are better than
they've ever been namely like Thor and
Wolverine Jason Aaron and Jeff Lemire I
don't want to leave you out but with
this discussion on Teen Titans rebirth
number one this really hits home for a
lot of people and the reason why is this
when people sit down and they look at
Teen Titans or they think about Teen
Titans they think of you know only a
handful of different things they think
of like you know Marv Wolfman run from
the early 1980s they think of Jeff Jon's
2003 run for a lot of people they think
of the cartoon show they think of Teen
Titans the show not Teen Titans go a
funny funny store when we were at New
York comic-con Benny had mentioned Teen
Titans go and like the crowd of you know
almost 400 people were just like boom
they hated Teen Titans go but I knew
Teen Titans was after my time to be
honest I was an Xfinity animated series
guy but 32 years old I grew up in the
early nineties late 80s Early 90s but
the fact remains here that when people
think of the Teen Titans show they think
of cyborg Robin Beast Boy Starfire Raven
they think of these characters that that
they grew up with you know that they
grew as these characters grew and so for
them you know it's their equivalent of
my ex be in the animated series it's the
equivalent you know their equivalent of
Justice League or Justice League
Unlimited you know it's it's what they
love into
of the characters and so with a new 52
launched and we got this new iteration
of the teen titans a lot of people hated
it a lot of people didn't really like it
because it wasn't the teen titans they
knew more so than that where people were
willing to give it a chance the story
riding just wasn't that good and so when
they looked back to you know that the
pre new 52 T Titans they said give us
that give us those those Teen Titans
that we remember now the issue with this
was that when the new 52 launched DC was
going for line wide reboot they were
saying look the age of the pre new 52 is
gone you know that's never coming back
of course we know it is now with DC we
berth and so GISI was very reluctant to
give fans what it was that they were
looking for with the beauty of geoff
johns spearheading this whole DC rebirth
project is that we get the Teen Titans
that we remember and in truth the way
the story is done the way those stories
put together the art really the
storytelling is just beautifully crafted
now initially we pick up with with Beast
Boy now Beast Boy is like
beast boys a fan favorite a lot of
different people that hail from the Teen
Titans the series just because of the
fact that Beast Boy was fun he was
adventurous he was interesting he had so
much personality he could shape-shift
into cool stuff you know people loved
that aspect of him and this really
continues here of course we have a party
and apparently Beast Boy just hijacks
the turntables but you know he's really
just kind of hanging out he's spending
time with a girl you know he decides
it's a good idea to turn into a shark
this is why Teen Titans rebirth is so
good um this is why Teen Titans rebirth
works it's like when Damian Wayne met
Superman's son it's not dramatic it's
not this great big huge grandiose thing
it's not this this opera it's just fun
it's good old-fashioned fun and this is
what Teen Titans need to be granted
there needs to be some storytelling with
regards to these teenagers and how they
deal with teenage things and how they
deal with life for example Beast Boy is
is for lack of a better word he's trying
to make good with the girl he's with and
he has no game is the best way to put it
he has no game whatsoever but you know
these Lee kind of things that make it
fun because it's in a lot of ways we saw
ourselves as Teen Titans but I guess not
really Teen Titans with teenagers I
never saw myself as a Teen Titan
although admittedly if I was given the
opportunity to be on Teen Titans
I would probably
take it hashtag don't judge me bro so
touchy over to Starfire this is also
where the Teen Titans begin to get a
little more interesting because to be
quite honest here
the Starfire was designed to be sex
appeal that's what she was she was
designed not really to be a sex object
so much as a reason to draw in young
boys
she is the rogue of the x-men from the
1990s animated series it doesn't mean
that she's taken away at all you know
the cool thing about about you know
Starfire is that she's in a world that's
not her own not only that there was a
lot of you know involvement between
herself and and Nightwing and one of the
great things about this is that DC
doesn't shy away they're like yeah you
know me and Nightwing were you know
touching on events at one point you know
that's what we were doing and and the
idea here is to basically say this is
the Starfire that you remember the
Starfire you got in the new food you to
that that era yes it was fun those
stories were kind of goofy but if what
you were wanting was the pre new 52 Teen
Titans era ass our fire this is what you
get this is the character that you crash
not from here we basically jump to Raven
now this is also where things get really
fun because I hope you guys are noticing
like we're getting like the kind of you
know the creme de la creme of the teen
titans things will change once we get to
Robin but we're getting the creme de la
creme of the Teen Titans the characters
that a lot of people know and love Raven
is is a character who was kind of like
struggling like she was like the emo
girl you know she just never quite fit
in but she found her own little home
with regards to them Teen Titans and the
reason why she's important here because
one the other thing I hope you guys
notice here is that each member of the
Teen Titans is designed to represent a
particular personality of a person or of
multiple people you have you know the
girl who's pretty and she's a little bit
ditzy but she's also really you know
capable to in the form of Starfire you
have to do that just loves to party with
regards to to Beast Boy and then you
have Raven who's kind of like the
outsider the emo chick doesn't quite fit
in you know but she still might have to
find a place of her own among her
various friends this is again really
just the the element of this character
that people love so much this is just
kind of a return to the Raven that folks
knew now is something else that I hope
you guys also notice is that each of
these individuals is basically being
kidnapped they're they're being attacked
from behind and that's really the gist
of this the gist of the rebirth story
isn't necessarily to to set the stage
and to say hey guys there's this great
big huge event going on you know what's
really just to say here's how they all
end up in the same place
now from here we jump to the new 52
wally west now this is actually a good
chain this is one of the things that
that's pretty solid here and here's why
I know there will be some people who
just don't want to see the new 52 Wally
West on any team but I think it works
when it comes to the Teen Titans by
definition they're supposed to be
teenagers you know it really wouldn't
make sense I guess you could call it
like the young adult Titans but that
doesn't have the same ring and so you
know having having kids who were
teenagers who are going through teenage
things is a huge part of the
storytelling that's one of the reasons
one of the things that drew so many
people into the Teen Titans
but for Wally West when he was rebooted
so to speak in the new 52 we got this
new iteration of him a lot of people
didn't like him who it was really
derisive there were people that looked
at him and they said well he's just a
caricature you know of young
african-american males there were people
that looked at him and said well he's
just not the red-haired Wally West so I
don't care about him and there were
people that looked at him and said well
he just doesn't fit in I mean it's just
he's a character that just doesn't fit
in any way it doesn't make any sense why
he's here and so while there were people
that also you know enjoyed him as well I
enjoyed him a bit you know depending on
what the story was it was going on um at
the end of the day he just kind of
seemed like a fish out of water and so
to turn around and take him and put him
on the Teen Titans gives him something
because one of the greatest things when
it comes to the team Titans again in
general is the character development the
characters evolving and changing and
growing with like Wally West for example
his character grew and changed a little
bit you know before crisis on Infinite
Earths when he was just kid flash but it
wasn't until Mark Waid took over riding
for his character in that I think late
1980s going up to the 1990s that his
character really grew and his character
really expanded not only that you know
having a Flash on the Teen Titans of
course that was Bart Allen for uh you
know for the before new 52 era the pre
no 52 era you know it adds a new dynamic
and the sense you've got a speedster but
Wally West is still trying to figure out
its powers still trying to figure out
how he fits in and so if it's perfect
under this team Titans dynamic on the
other half of this though is it's keep
in mind he's also in a flash series he's
also a you know alongside Barry Allen
but the cool thing about this is that
Wally West is very confident
he's very sure of himself even if he
shouldn't necessarily be that confident
in that true of himself because his
powers aren't everything they're cracked
up to be but again you know just like
everybody else before him he's suddenly
taken by surprise and he's basically
knocked out and so at this point what we
do is you basically pick up with the
tail end of his story and and we
essentially take up with Wally West
Starfire beast boy and Raven and they're
all
held captive and so the idea here at
least what they seem to be indicating is
that hey we got to figure out what's
going on I mean of course you would hope
they would but then their captor reveals
himself to be Damian Wayne now this is a
huge kicker this is this is actually a
huge change for Teen Titans it doesn't
seem that big but its massive and the
reason for this is because people who
grew up with the Teen Titans show they
were like Tim Drake Tim Drake is a
leader of the Teen Titans use Robin in
that series as nobody else it's always
Tim Drake and I think a lot of people
probably wanted to see Tim Drake come
back the issue with this is that Tim
Drake's / Tim Drake's not really a
teenager Tim Drake's going on with his
own life as a sands right now he's being
held captive by mr. Oz but people wanted
to see you know some measure of
familiarity and I think that with Damian
Wayne being a teenager I think that with
Damian Wayne coming into his own with so
much character development coming after
you know Robin son of Batman coming
after Batman and Robin you know all
these these story actually going on
right now with regards to the main
Batman continuity you know within a solo
series of the type of comics I think it
creates a perfect stage for Damian Wayne
to evolve in and of himself alongside
his own peers not only that you know as
a character that's so isolated as a
character that's so alone as a character
that it really grew up essentially being
trained to be an assassin Damian Wayne
in a lot of ways locked he lacks social
skills you know he just doesn't have
social skills the way that they're
supposed to be developed at his age and
so to see him effectively take over the
Teen Titans means then we'll probably
see him grow and we'll see him change
even more so than we have which again is
always a great theme because it adds a
whole new different dynamic which in
turn folds into the Batman and detective
comics line of stories and then it gives
us a whole different dynamic in terms of
those stories with Damian Wayne and how
it relates to Batman and especially
Jonathan Kent
Superman's son and so again you know
this rebirth issue wasn't really
designed you know I get to set the stage
and to say hey there's this great big
huge thing I mean there is you know and
of course you basically have we're gonna
have the Teen Titans going against Ra's
al Ghul but the gist of all this is to
say hey guys you know here is a Teen
Titans that you remember here's the Teen
Titans that you wanted in the new 52 and
this is the Teen Titans that you're
getting in DC rebirth go crazy go wild
so with that being said we're gonna
bring this to an end again I know I know
it's not like our regular fare of videos
but I felt like was something about the
Teen Titans because there are so many
people that grew up with him because the
Teen Titans are so personal for a lot of
different coming but fans I wanted to
sort of give you guys this understanding
at least people who are new to the
Gork I give you guys this understanding
in terms of why people are so excited
with Teen Titans rebirth and why it's
proving itself to really be one of the
standout publications in DC we berth
right now but if you guys are new here
to comics explain make sure you guys hit
that subscribe button to become part of
the Rob core and drop a like if you guys
enjoyed this video also if you're not
following me on Twitter make sure you
guys follow me on Twitter comments
explain sometimes I drop videos early so
that people November's of the rod port
get to see them before anybody else does
but or at least before I upload them on
YouTube because I have to maintain that
schedule but with that being said we're
gonna bring this video to an end and
yeah I will catch you all later peace